entscheidungen extrem wie freiheit
zurück machen wenn ich mich mal entweder
hat biss und natur und musik geist
wohnort logisches christian hug besser
oder einen anhang besser nein das ist
ein italo meditieren im gras sich
bescheiden auf ihre sache ich hoffe dass
wir auch
nein ich habe es wirklich sage ich ich
hatte viele ideen weiter
ich lasse jetzt mal zu
[Musik]
ja heute zusammen zu einer neue volk
fleisch und bossard mit der barbara und
mit mehrheit live aus basel mit einer
großartigen publikum
[Applaus]
gleich selber gerade nirgendwo damit
trete man über beziehungen und fragt
warum liebe eigentlich so kompliziert
ich
mir bei die händler ihr beziehungsstatus
langweilig und so lange musik ist eben
verheiratet aber von der weißen des
früheren einander stehen also nicht mehr
handy bezirk schuleingang auto show
arbeitet man aber früher nachts wieder
kompliziert sie erst mal zeit im amt
bewähren ich glaube aber die show
schreckensruf dass mütter seite aus gibt
die generation
beziehungsunfähig darf es völlig normal
dass mit zwischen 20 und chris christoph
thiem jedes laufes godfrey drunter und
drüber peter meister das gehört zur mit
probierte einiges aus mir schon suchen
erzählt und nahe dass sich
überhaupt nicht in heimischer und ruß
und selbst wenn man muss eine dem er als
opa prolet das ist schade dass ich bei
ihnen findet das kind nicht aus
öffentlichkeit interessanter
stimmbezirks status öffentlich gemacht
auf facebook war ja wieso kann das mache
ich nicht warum
die privat
ja
also ich habe es mit den partnern in
weiß das und wenn sie denken gab
gesprochen dass ich bin
ja aber keine story broke was macht man
im blick es gibt ja die diagnose
exhibitionismus mir fehlt natürlich ganz
anders gewesen wo ist aber der druck
noch mal zu dämmen generation
beziehungsunfähig für seine these die
hand von michael nast umsatz 2015 sollen
einem blog-post abgeschrieben hat noch
ist ein roman wurden oder andere
inzwischen bestseller und an verfilmt
und ich weiß wie du es aber mich stört
dass immer wenn man sozusagen
irgendwelche zieht phänomen nimmt und
den seit die generation ist so und so
einzig was interessant finde ist dass
ihr seid ja eigentlich schon mitte 40
ist neue ghriskey und irgendwie hat sich
viele besucher verschleppt also die
phase von muss probieren franz 10
dazwischen diskutiert und
diagnose beziehungsformen setzt sich
fort aber viel kriegen denn nur wenn es
irgendwann hat bei mir sein was genau
denn ich glaube also wer mit so
vorschnell wie du und wird sage das ist
nur dass es altes phänomen und das
wertigen beinen schwer den aleviten fix
ii bezieher kreis bezirks material ich
glaube wieder verändert sich gerade bis
finden pluralisierung staaten
individualisierung also meine trainer
ist entweder den freundin kam also ein
bisschen partnerschaft sie hier den
äther schicken wir freundschaft plus als
offene bca du hast du hast du hast
single sie aber überzeugte singles sie
und ich finde es ist ein riesengewinn
muss man mal sagen wir können noch
darüber dass das auch problematisch ist
die schwierigkeit der mit sich bringt
und verbindlichkeit und stress und
überforderung aber grundsätzlich muss
man extrem
emanzipation befremdlich mal weg von dem
ein korsett und
knapp hinter der mieterinnen gestattung
bescheinigt aber frühere herrscher hatte
ich gar nicht können scheiterten aber
dass frau das gesicht verloren bis
finanziell abhängig und somit genauso
gut gehen aber ein kater ist sicher ganz
groß zwischen großer emanzipation akt
vor allem für frauen absolut gesehen ja
so einfach eine vierergruppe zum
beispiel wo möglichkeit anträge beziehen
zumindest und eine
gesellschaftliche gruppen aber kein
freilauf und ganz wichtig dass man den
betrieb mit tänzen seit jahren reizt das
alles nicht geht natürlich immer dass
ich sogar so dass wir eigentlich die
romantische zweier gäste die schon
neueren datums also wenn es im 18
jahrhundert wirkt es ist völlig normal
dass man nach freiheit sich immer
komisch sie eine kleinigkeit die
bürgerliche ehe hat aldrin bestanden
dass man aber trainer sind die anderen
lok verliebt hat und an geschichte ist
gar nicht dankbar sie und ich glaube sie
hat da die über hörig vor der
romantische zweier bezirk wo seligen
jahr von mitte 20 und 3 bis 5 münster
und das ist denn da so wahrscheinlicher
betrachtet wie sie ja dann immer so hoch
so unglaublich verliebt sie bis zwei
intensiv sie es muss geborgenheit
muskelschmerz xii das ist das ja eh alle
bürger viel mehr werte der coach dass
das konstrukt zu zeigen so stark
verinnerlicht dass du meinst du musst
ich das und bin ich viel wert so
zugeschnitten dass du das
bedürfnis begehren ist immer ein
konstruiert hollywood aus drei fabriken
ideal werdet ihr schwert und das ist
schon sehr stark das ist die schlosserei
oder sich die letzte jugendbefragung die
show für euch parat aber die hat zeigt
dass die jugendlichen sicher was ich das
klappt 17 20 uhr steht frau gegeben die
ihr träumt immer noch regiert die
glaswand eigentlich
ganz viel wand sind ganz viel warnt
sogar am allerliebsten spitze schafft
untermalung der prozent also sehr
klassische rollenbilder und auf jeden
fall zwei orchester also ich freue mich
so dittli stimmt dass er bewirkt also
wieder generation beziehungsunfähig
steht der traum ist eine relativ
konstante frage warum und ich würde
natürlich auch sagen traum sind die
träume sind immer dazu da hat gesagt es
bilder wurden nicht real ist dh es hätte
ja wieso garnier die ewige romantische
liebe gehetzt wahrscheinlich garnier nur
um 3
ich hoffe es ist hat eine starke
sehnsucht
wird mit über schmerz und ganz
auf gott und verstand
doch
nicht immer
finden wodurch sich verstört wir
akzeptieren das vertrauen
nein ich bin wirkt das ist schon
interessanter die philosophie katze
unterschiedliche ideen was hier die ist
und es geht das verschmelzen modell es
gibt aber
ebenso von
der resonanz burger 2 wo sich gaga 70
ansprache und wo irgendwie schwierig zu
sagen wo höhere 2 blieb naja was heißt
schon tierisch jagd heißt das nicht so
mit deine sache spirituell ist
hochgradig
genau also jetzt die zeit ist eigentlich
ein große befreiung motto würde ich
sagen du sagst es gibt zwar also eher
konservativ backlash richtig verstehen
ist wieder zurück einfamilienhäuser
bezirk hund und so
aber nicht wahrsagen fehle ihm hätte der
umfrage macht importen zufällig sind
überfordert also mit der
unverbindlichkeit es gibt das phänomen
dass fear of missing out also immer
angst das ich verpasse es könnte besser
schön dass sie das empathische stosur
war der bewohner bis zu mir passt hier
kaufen supermarkt mentalität in sachen
in sachen beziehung auch glaube dass
beschäftigt viele liegt absolut und
erfordert zeit und da ging er schon gar
nicht mit müssen dies einig dass es bis
der freien zeit wie sie jetzt ist die
große auswahl die möglichkeit dass man
ihn ja alles ausprobiert und zwar nicht
nur zwischen 20 und christian reich
verhindern ich bin in der mode ich
spreche ja grundsätzlich natürlich dass
emanzipation potenzial und besprochen
hat aber entscheidungen
extremismus mache wenn ich mich mal
entweder hat bis zum nennwert und muss
nur geliebt weiß wo noch logisch
christian am hag besser oder einen
anhang besser
meditieren im gras sich bescheiden auf
ihre sache ich muss das unmögliche
aufgabe
ich wirklich ich hatte viel weiter
ich lasse jetzt nur eine seite
entscheide ich so wichtig für die
freiheit zu rufen dass man wirklich sehr
schlecht ja ja aber engagement und b
aber diese nicht für sich irgendwo
dazwischen oder irgendwo da viel wie
groß das macht stellt der muss steht für
bier geführte konten das korsett dienen
von der gesellschaft was noch zwei
sachen angeht aber vielleicht sturmowski
bezichtigte polyamorie
von sexuell
dass ich eigentlich gut genau das tut
das lieber willi sagen dass der gewinner
kommen community es geht die möglichkeit
hat der tankt datingportal sie findet
partner oder partnerin wo andere
vorlieben finden die augen schließt sich
das oft eine möglichkeit das führte dazu
dass du die spuren hinterfragt es
beginnt so extrem individualisiert nicht
nur was die rasse wie wir es alle kreise
der jobgarantie bewohnt sondern auch wie
man liebe dich kommt s neues buch und
julia show über die sexualität einfach
und sie seit natürlich zeitgemäß ist es
wenig überraschend die these finde der
mir zur aufweitung gerettet eigentlich
sind wahrscheinlich sie sei
es geht es spektrum sowie sexualität es
gibt wenige die sind ganz klar
homosexuell wenige sind ganz klar 6 1
und ganz viel liebe weckt zudem spektrum
und worum letztes mal ausprobieren und
ich gehöre hinter natürlich du sagt es
probiert doch endlich mal was macht
eigentlich verdienen wie der pc ist es
ja schon der impuls und ich finde
ich richtig versteht es entsteht und
trug
einzigartig und ausgefallene
beziehungsmodell ab und wenn man
sozusagen konventionell erlaubt so wie
du und ich schon solche haut so das ist
sensationell ist doch jeder sieht sie
als richtige zieht
nächste mal wird sie das weiß ich nicht
das genau das ist das retro trend also
dass widerrufen
es ist schwierig aber ich meine these
ist winter sand oder diagnose bastia
zusammen mit der regierung these vom
andreas ragwitz vor einem sozialbau seit
gesellschaft der singularität wird wenn
man alles einzigen drei zitat ich sie
also ich sich leider dieses morgens
müsli und alles muss irgendwie
authentisch sich also das authentische
einzigartige und und die autonomie geben
wir das sind ganz privat und das ist
interessant werden dies schlägt sich
dort hinter der wieder enormen ihnen
momentan skoda um ihn befähigt aber
letztlich ist vielleicht ein trend um
rund 100 genau davon dass meine kinder
and casino in wirklich viele studis
ausprobierens der durchsuchung sondern
wird und nicht wie normal sie sage ich
jetzt mal und das nur mit dem trend zur
individualisierung wurden aus begehren
mittlerweile betrifft und wo ich mein
gewicht ich glaube es schon eigentlich
interessant dass individualisierte unit
nur damit du etwas zu ende wo zu mir
passt sondern sierau ab sofort ein
anderer das könnt ihr ganz stark
eigentlich als zu und täter wiederum
stehen die interessant was macht
eigentlich barbe zwar bezieht briest
zugehörigkeit als eigentlich unitis
individuum sondern zusammen und maxi und
oftmals haben wir den jetzigen mir
langweilig und er vielleicht versteckt
loyalität und so auch enz gezogen andere
bilder mit der langen beziehung verbinde
wo wir zusperren freundschaft der
schätze zu spielen ist doch großartig
wenn ich jetzt durchgeführte zahnpasta
tube führen er würde alle deuten rubin
wo
schottland würdet lachen wir sie wüsste
was mit der zahnpasta tube der herr
logisch will die politik hat mir nie
erzählt anhand der geschichte aufzug
bezug nein und das ist eigentlich
irgendwo durch findet wohl hamm ii
bezieher großartig macht an
liebesbeziehung
ja es gibt sogar philosophie sagt das
macht sie einzigartig
letztlich liebst du erdschicht
produzieren und das du überzieht zu
seelenverwandten wurde bist so
will eigentlich mit der frage was nicht
für einen grund mini partner in sachen
aber letztlich konnten aber die sache
über die eigenschaft der arbeit oder das
was ist einzigartig was verbinden und
ist selber schuld
dafür
zum zudem bindet man musste immer frage
menschen das wichtigste ich bin
mir gar nicht bekommen
genau durch zeit effektiv die
verbindlichkeit die die bindung von
start und ich finde da geht's dem weg
und wenn eine berühmte philosoph so eine
schöne dialektische fand ich interessant
finde er seit freiheit die war die
freiheit ein sturm riss albis oder
bindet andere die das ganz normal
fangzeit das finde ich super gedanke da
seid dazu mich selbst windig basiert
nicht einfach für dich selber sondern du
bist im andere idee selber und das
findet die art für die elektrik t shirt
einfach weg heute komme ich vom
individuum muss und dankt also mit lars
entwurf und wellness welle partnerin
passte zu mehr das leben an sich weit
und das findet das wenig förderung
verkehr wählen gezielt
transformiert mich auch immer und macht
mich zum ein anderer mensch und zeigt
hier erst wer als entwurf ich wirklich
weg im idealfall soll ich dir völlig
achte und interessantes kleine schritte
vergessen gegangen stimmt die
philosophie unit und typische ließ
wahrheit die sache wieder mal trifft
kohl und bleibt die feministische
philosophie worum weil die familie
philosophie natürlich immer schon vor
abhängigkeit zur verletzlichkeit uns
dank haid und immer schon verstanden wir
sind eben nicht so einzelne pilz wie das
der thomas hobbes zeit ja das schließt
auch irgendwie so aus importen user
thomas hobbes
thomas hobbes nicht willst dass das
untertor verbunden ist aber im grund das
bild von p s stimmt nicht sondern wir
sind verbunden miteinander verwoben sind
das geflecht und die dämmung immer
abhängig voneinander und das finde ich
ganz wichtig was eigentlich tv
illustrierten
immer wieder betont hat dass die heutige
jedes modell wo aber sehr stark mit dem
dating plattformen auf den beruhigt dass
du partner und partnerinnen ausprobieren
schließt paar schuhe und wenn sie eine
paste dänisches und wenn sie doch
klatschten trübswasser völlig server
oder ich muss sagen
dass ich die tendenz die tanzschule
obliege der android-plattform aber
schade denn blieben also die these nicht
wirklich dass sie seit das ist so ein
großer teil und das vor allem unter
frauen nicht entgangen weil die negative
bändiger wie sie es nennt mit dem
anschnitt schlacht die gesunde ob die
findige sind die wovon der stadt reiche
tourismus treiber sind also dreht
befriedigung werks schnelle sex ohne
verbindlichkeit geht eine frau war das
schätzt aber meistens wo einander
suchend und worauf du also das ist
schade dass großes thema ist keine frage
aber was ich nicht die kleine
frau würden alle im beruf grund ist dass
frauen sich zum teil den früh oder
wandbilder wie sie irgendwann damit
konfrontiert sind ob sie warnt mit der
familie gründen und die frage stellt
ihre frau einfach früher immer
ja das ist ein punkt aber wenn andere
also würde wetter lag aber das was das
bild von einer dating- erbsen partner
website gut ich glaube ich weiß mir sehr
klar war es mir auf welcher plattform
sind und sollten also das ist ja wie
gesagt das ist ein neues sie vor 15
jahren ist das vielleicht zog sich hat
weiß man doch lieber mit dem umbau
ich musste über aber sprühend reizt
natürlich das hätte wegen die partys
klar unterlegen trotz keiner klebt essen
oder das kurz beherrschen interessiert -
das ist alles gar nicht so neu
ausführlich das glaube ich besprach das
gekritzel die these die er die
jugendlichen oder die junge generation
unternahm sie vor allem unternehmen wie
haben sie ihren ironischen umgang mit
dem alles ihren spielerischen umgang und
und könnte aus und zündeten sie richter
partner oder partnerin wo sie länger mit
einer zange sind sogar eine party wie
der freunde und kinder und porsche und
all die sachen die nicht doch sogar
zudem spielerisch ausprobieren parship
übrigens du immer wieder soziale
publizieren und betont immer dass zwei
drittel von der beziehung geschlossen
werden feucht bis ca haltet und zwar
länger die angriffe sogar ja und
gleichzeitig glaube nein ich meine der
typ gefragt und
sie haben dass die vier of michigan alt
also die angst ist verpasse und hat
schon die idee geht es dennoch wohl
besser zu mir wird was ja und das finde
ich irgendwo dorian schiebt die frage
ist also kann ich mich so doch nicht
gestellt sondern nur wie stellst du doch
ab und zwar so muss darstellen was kann
ich machen dass ich ihre bezieht dass
wir dies gemeinsam so weiterentwickelt
dass beide parteien das ist ein schönes
projekt zeigt das ist ein wichtige
punkten stichwort projekt oder mit dem
erich fromm heißt dass kunst des lebens
das leben ist geschenk so eine dumme
schafe nachdem und das fing schon
interessanter punkt vielleicht stehen
die diagnose ist das erhöht löst man im
bezirk schnell einzigen jahr steigen
werde das tut auch weh oder wenn man
sich der landrat der bernd müssen gott
weder zunächst und das finde ich meine
schuhe haben die koreanisch philosoph
aus burgstädt palliativ gesellschaft das
mit dem arzt das wagnis dass man das
einfach solche raum tragen und das geht
es mir gar nicht ausmalen
auf das ewige und haltet nicht aus und
schaffen und das klappt das braucht's
das buch
zusammen das kriegt man habe kindheit
oder das ist so schrecklich manta b
events zum fenster der raiders verlaufen
sagt
disney crash dann egal war eine
beziehung wenn du zurück los was hätte
ich weiß das sind sagt krise ziehen die
schweren schlag gegen beide eine gute
beziehung gar nicht und wenn ich andere
richtigen als unsere bereitet bleibt ja
total ambivalent oder will genau das
wieder die frage wie lange seine ideen
aus horn in die kurt masur toxische
bezüge sind so schwieriger beruf aber
ich finde insgesamt die frage wenn
bliebe und sage dass ich dass ich
wirklich noch der wert zum treffen der
musikus haare mit dem schmerz umgang mit
der wird mit den duschen und wenn es
stimmen sagen ich habe bis besser
verdient mit partnerin bis besser
studieren miteinander einfach einen gut
geht doch bei max frisch die schöne
stellen wunder seit wir haben uns immer
nur verkleinert warum haben wir uns
immer nur verkleinert und das während
die sohn des schönes bildet ich finde es
muss in ihrem bezirk darum gar ein
anderer größer loswerden technische
bezieht das was heißt das das hat damals
selbst im hause
ich habe
ja
auch schon recht früh bereits
jetzt zeige ich es gibt also das ist es
gibt im real care die vorstellung das
ist etwas charme andere ist dass man das
zu lauter sechs tage in relief machst du
es mir ist bessere ich hatte bringt das
vieh zum zum vorschein aber
transformationen derzeit ja aber die
haben die bilanz blieb was heißt jetzt
da also das was heißt das konkret wenn
sie immer in einer sackgasse in men ist
das quartett wenn bin ich mich selber
und und noch so viel schlaf hilft nehme
ich glaube das war letztlich nur die
dafür selber beantworten indem wir gute
beobachtungsgabe in dem offenen android
und der mit der mutter als auch meine
bezirksbeamten längeres sie tut einfach
extrem
und muss eine der sachen pc funktioniert
ich extrem viel glück will es gibt in
der schweiz sehr viele singles stiegen
die zahl also das muss man sich mal vor
augen aber sind wir gewohnt genau und
lasse frauen ohne große diskussion geht
es nicht ohne diskriminierung von single
da sie aus werden minderwertige ladens
worden ist es selbstverständlich nicht
aber sie schauen tatsache dass es für
single geht weiterhin auf der suche sind
und es alle steckten potenzielle single
während ihrer zeit an verlor werte für
witwe was auch immer und von daher ist
es gut beraten nicht nur als
veranstalter sondern
gut trainiert und mit sich selbst
geschlagen aber ist natürlich ein großer
schritt zurück taste vorstellen 50
jahren die beziehungsmodell sehr
vielfältiger sehen dass sie jetzt sind
und liegt damit sechs kiew die bezirke
hemd und dem motto partner erklärt oder
friends with benefits and und zur
wiederherstellung
vorstellung dass wir nachlegen
revolution stattfinden
das ist drei philosophische frage sag
ich jetzt in philosoph
ich weiß es wirklich nicht 3 jannik also
man so gute zukunft diagnose findet so
immer christ
rangers wert es gibt sich realisierung
lebensform aber wie gesagt es gibt auch
die relativ konstant die sehnsucht nach
der romantischen zwei riesig und david
und frau unter den blüten bereits so
viel über pro jahr so viel wie wir den
salat polyamorie zumindest eine baracke
ja 4% trend zur vorstellung pauli habe
als er sich jetzt messen sagt wie viel
man über polyamorie rettig setzt nicht
durchschlagen die neuheiten ich bin
philosophisch noch richtige organisieren
interessant die drogen client zu fahren
ist können wir überhaupt lieber ohne
konvention ohne vorstellung ohne ideal
ohne code also das ist das doch ich sage
zählt einfach egal wie man das nennt wie
was für die nato bekennen das ist das
was das neue ideal sehr
individualistisch sehr auf authentizität
und acht hat aber das klassische im
amerika schublade sondern einfach derby
und ich glaube das ist das paradox
philosophisch erstens wenn es
psychologisch allerdings sehen wir noch
hinter es bei einem notruf werden
abgefüllt mit
konventionen und liebes ideal in filmen
und büchern sowie das erste und zweite
überhaupt begrifflich fassbar also wien
ähnlich denn das oft braucht mario
inbegriff von 1000 erst dann weiß man
sich wirklich sicher dass man das führt
da haben sich die frage ist das wirklich
was mit der hand oder ist das nur der
freundschaft und so spielten
ich sehe ich merke das gratis
verlost du bitte mal auf oder
mehrstufig machen aber zuerst fertig
mache
ja wie ist das buch wie ihr liebe der
und wie kompliziert das baby ist doch
ich kommentar
danke meinen verpassen abonnieren kanal